foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's webinar titled
Armory T cells with engineered Fusion
proteins enhances therapeutic efficacy
against hematological and solid tumors
this webinar is a part of the 10th
Annual cancer research and immuno
oncology week
I am antonina Salcido of lab roots and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and sponsored by
stem cell Technologies for more
information about stem cell Technologies
please go to stemcell.com
now let's get started
before we begin I'd like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to First participate by
communicating with other attendees using
our new live chat feature during the
presentation you can also participate by
submitting as many questions as you
would like during the presentation to do
so simply type them into the ask the
question box and click submit
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation click on the help desk
button located at the bottom of your
screen within the navigation bar or from
the lobby
finally as a reminder this presentation
is educational and offers free
continuing education credits click on
the continuing education credits link
located in the abstract window on the
sidebar to the left of the presentation
and follow the process to obtain your
credits
I now present today's speaker Dr Shannon
Oda assistant professor at the bend Town
Center for Childhood Cancer Research and
the University of Washington School of
Medicine
for a complete biography on our speakers
please visit the biography tab at the
left of your screen
Dr Oda you may now begin your
presentation
I would like to thank the organizers for
the opportun opportunity to talk about
our work today where we will be
discussing our marine T cells with
engineered Fusion proteins to enhance
therapeutic efficacy against
hematological and solid tumors
here are my disclosures
so it's an exciting time for cancer
immunotherapy where several basic
immunological discoveries have led to
breakthroughs in the clinic which has
led to an increasing increasing
appreciation that the immune system can
be harnessed to control and eradicate
cancer this has been shown in multiple
Publications now and also in the Nobel
Prize awarded in 2018 for the discovery
of immunotherapy by inhibition of
negative immune regulation
so in my lab we work to restore the
anti-cancer immune response with T Cell
adoptive immunotherapy which we like to
call a living drug and so what I mean by
that is that we isolate blood from the
patient and we get T cells we remove
those T cells from the blood we
genetically engineer those T cells in
the lab to Target them to tumor and then
we grow millions of those T cells that
we can then Infuse back into the patient
so that those living cells can migrate
throughout the body to search out and
Destroy cancer
so there are two major types of adoptive
cell therapy T cells the first is
chimeric antigen receptor or car T cells
and these are fairly well known for
their success against cb19 positive
tumors and with car T cells you can
Target surface proteins which represent
about 27 of the total protein these are
HLA non-restricted so you do not have to
match the antigen receptor with the HLA
type of the patient
we commonly use tcrs instead or T cell
receptors so with tcrt cells you're able
to Target both intracellular and
extracellular peptide antigens these are
HLA restricted so you do have to match
the HLA of the TCR with the patients HLA
but there are several antigens that are
being targeted by this method including
nyeso wt1 and mesophyline
so in a recent paper from Eric trans
group he showed that tcrt cells can be
effective against solid tumors so here
we're looking at images of a tumor
before treatment and after treatment
with ccrt cells showing significant
regression of this pancreatic pancreatic
tumor nodule with the tcrt cell therapy
so with the tcrt cell platform even with
finding a great TCR or a car we know
that there are still several obstacles
in the tumor microenvironment that can
inhibit the anti-tumr T Cell response so
T cells can compete with tumor cells for
key nutrients there's often a lack of
cost inventory ligands in the tumor
microenvironment which could provide a
positive signal for T cells instead
there's often inhibitory ligand
expression and soluble factors that
inhibit T cells the tumors can down
regulate their target antigen or HLA and
T cells themselves can become exhausted
and this can be further potentiated by
the lack of missing or the lack of
supportive cells in the tumor
microenvironment
so in my lab we asked how we can armor
our T cells to overcome these obstacles
and rather than address each of these
obstacles individually we're looking for
opportunities to develop engineering
strategies to address as many of these
obstacles as possible within one
carefully engineered approach
so we develop novel engineering
strategies using engineered Fusion
proteins which combine two native
proteins to form a new hybrid protein so
we take the extracellular domain of one
protein and combine that with the
intracellular domain of a second protein
to form a new fusion protein that is not
found in nature but is formed from two
native proteins resulting in a very low
immunogenicity approach
and with this approach we can deliver
co-simulatory signals which can initiate
gene expression programs and T cells to
counter several obstacles
so customulatory signals can enhance the
proliferative proliferation of T cells
or their ability to multiply in the
patient we can get a enhanced
tumorsolysis resistance to exhaustion
increase longevity and memory formation
as well as altered metabolism of our T
cells dependent on the co-similatory
signal that we select
so as I mentioned one of the issues
within the tumor microenvironment is
that tumor cells can express proteins on
the surface of the cell that shut down
the T cell so when this inhibitory
protein is expressed by the tumor cell
or other inhibitory cells within the
tumor microenvironment it can bind to
the inhibitory receptor on the T cell
and shut down the T cell and impeding it
from lysine tumor cell
so one of our approaches is to
essentially replace a break with an
accelerator where we are rewiring
inhibitory or death receptor signaling
so to do that we take the ectodomain of
an inhibitory or death receptor and then
we replace the intracellular domain with
a co-stimulatory receptor signaling
domain
so now instead of an inhibitory signals
T cells get a stimulatory boost from the
switch receptor
so when the T Cell binds to its
inhibitory protein the switched receptor
delivers a positive signal the T cell is
able to again lyce tumor
so we have now shown that switch
receptors can enhance multiple T Cell
functions including T Cell proliferation
so here we're showing with a phosphor
mbb switch receptor that we published
that we can get a robust proliferation
of our T cells relative to TCR only T
cells and this is to a very low level of
stimulation we can get metabolic
reprogramming so here we're showing
increased mitochondrial biogenesis with
a phosphor mbb engineered T cell and we
can also get increased uh production of
functional cytokines from our human T
cells so this is human T cell data
showing that we're able to get robust
quantities of tnf Alpha and il2
production from our switch receptor
engineer T cells
so one of the cancers that we focus on
in my lab is acute myelide leukemia or
AML and this is an important cancer to
develop new strategies for as the
survival rate lagged behind other blood
cancers so the five-year Survivor rate
is around 26 for AML patients
we also work on pancreatic cancer in my
lab and this is also a very serious
disease that has a survival rate that
has not improved so in this chart we can
see the changes in survival from the 7
News to 2010 2011 for a variety of
cancers and this reflects improvements
in early detection as well as
therapeutic options but pancreatic
cancer is down here at the very bottom
with about a 10 5-year survival rate and
it's predicted to become the second most
deadliest cancer by 2030. some of the
challenges with pancreatic cancer are
that early detection is uncommon
pancreatic cancer tends to spread
quickly and recurrence is likely
so one of the targets that we wanted to
go after with our switch receptor
platform was cd47 and this is a very
highly sought after Target as it is
overexpressed in most adult tumors so
here we're looking at overexpression of
cd47 in the tumor tissues shown here in
the red bars versus normal healthy
tissue in the black bars
dd47 is also overexpressed in pediatric
tumors so here we're showing cd47
expression by mRNA in a variety of
pediatric tumors
specifically in pancreatic cancer cd47
is significantly overexpressed and high
expression correlates with reduced
survival so in panel B you can see that
the patients that have high cd47
expression in red have a worse survival
than the patients that have low cd47
expression in the blue line
so the syrup Alpha cd47 interaction can
inhibit anti-tumor immunity by multiple
mechanisms one mechanism is that this
axis inhibits macrophages from
phagocytosine cancer cells and another
mechanism is that cd47 signaling can
inhibit dendritic cell antigen
presentation to T cells so there are
multiple opportunities for us to address
this access to improve our anti-tumor
immunity
so cd47 has been targeted by antibodies
and shown here in this mouse model these
antibodies modestly controlled
pancreatic tumor progression
however one of the issues with cd47
targeted drug therapies is that they can
cause anemia issues as cd47
is also expressed on red blood cells and
so if you block that signals and
macrophages can phagocytose normal
healthy red blood cells
so our approach is to develop a serp
alpha cd28 switch receptor that combines
the serp alpha Echo domain with cd28
which is a co-simulatory signal for T
cells to develop this new fusion protein
to address the cd47 overexpression on
tumor cells
so to develop this switch receptor I
developed a panel of fusions that
combined different sections of serp
alpha with cd28 so shown here in the red
are the sections of serp alpha that were
Incorporated the extracellular domain
and with the first Fusion also extending
into the transmembrane domain and then
in the blue are the portions of cd28
that were included in these different
switch receptors so the last four switch
receptors have cd28 that extends out
into the extracellular space and
includes an extracellular cysteine and
this is to promote dimerization of the
protein or the receptor which is known
to enhance cb28 signaling
additionally what we've shown in our
previous work is that it's important to
also consider the size of the ectodomain
of the switch receptor so the space
between the T cell and the tumor cell is
actually a very narrow space where the
immunological synapses and so in order
for our switch receptors to co-localize
to the immunological synapse which is
where Native cp28 signaling occurs we
want to have appropriately sized Ecto
domains and so what we've shown
previously is that if you have too large
of an ectodomain it's effectively
excluded from the immunological synapse
so with these switch receptors we also
took that into consideration and so we
truncated the ectodomain of serp alpha
to accommodate those extra amino acids
from cd28 in the last two fusions on the
right
to the first second and then the red
fusion preserve the T cell tumor cell
synapse distance
so similar to what we had previously
discovered we found that serp Alpha cd28
constructs that are engineered to
maintain the T cell tumor cell distance
exhibited enhanced proliferation so
those three fusions that I showed on the
previous slide that are appropriately
sized to fit with immunological synapse
were able to promote proliferation of
our engineered T cells in the red
relative to our TCR only controls in the
blue
we also did multiple stimulation assays
which we found to be effective in
determining which search receptors are
developing or promoting the best
customer Choice signals and with this
assay we found that there were two
fusions in particular that exhibited
increased ability to accumulate T cells
upon multiple stimulations so both the
serp alpha transmembrane fusion and also
the surf Alpha fusion with the -9 amino
acids that had the truncated serpatha to
accommodate those extra amino acids from
c28
so we tested this in a mouse model for
AML and we found that whereas the switch
to receptor that had the sort of alpha
transmembrane did not greatly improve
therapeutic efficacy relative to our
tcrt only in the black our serp Alpha
minus 9 amino acid Fusion did
significantly enhance therapy relative
to our tcrt only
so we continued with these studies with
our
um
are pancreatic cancer cells and so this
is an assay looking at the ability of
our TCR T cells or switch receptor tcrt
cells to lice pancreatic cancer cells in
the incusite assay and so we found that
the leading Fusion had provided much
better ability for rot cells to lace
tumor relative to our tcrt cell control
in the black
so to test the strategy in Vivo with
solid tumors we use the KPC genetically
engineered Mass model of pancreatic
ductile adenocarcinoma
and this mouse is a fantastic model it
has mutations in k-ras and p53 and this
recapitulates 80 of human and pancreatic
cancers which also have mutations in
these two genes
so these mutations are held under a
pancreas-specific Cree so these might
spontaneously and continuously generate
tumors from epithelial cells in the
pancreas so because these mites are
constantly developing new tumors we'll
never be able to cure these mice but
hopefully we can shift the curve with
our approaches in this model
the KPC model has been used to screen
drugs to predict therapeutic efficacy in
patients so that's very important for us
to be able to determine what's effective
in this Mass model and be able to move
into clinical trials
and to the KPC model recapitulates
several barriers to T cell function of
human ppda including a suppressive
microenvironment
so it has been shown that mesotheelin is
a tumor antigen that's reliably
overexpressed in the various stages of
pancreatic Dental adenocarcinoma as well
as in the KPC Mouse
however with mesothel and targeted T
cells even with that targeting it was
shown in this paper that those T cells
become rapidly dysfunctional in the
tumor microenvironment so by day eight
post-transfer these T cells are already
less able to make affect your cytokines
including interferon gamma and tnf Alpha
relative to their counterparts in the
spleen
so to use this model we screen the mice
by ultrasound to determine when tumors
arise so on the left we have a healthy
Mouse with a normal pancreas and on the
right side you can see that there are
tumor modules and so we enroll those
mice to study
so once those tumors are detected we
enroll them as to study as we would do
patients and then we give them an
enrollment dose of a single dose of
cyclophosphamide which is similar to
what we do in our in the clinic and then
we give them a dose of T cells
um as well as mesophilin as an antigen
boost
day 7 post transfer we assess the T
cells in the blood and we checked their
tumor burden by ultrasound
and then we give them an additional two
doses of T cells without
cyclophosphamide for a total of three
doses of T cells and then we checked the
mice for the duration of the study
so
importantly
um this is a very challenging scenario
for our T cells who are not giving them
il-2 injections we're not giving them my
style two injections in Vivo so we're
not supporting the T cells with il-2 and
Vivo they must be il2 independent
um or at least some exogenous II and
we're limiting the number of T Cell
transfers to three whereas previous
Publications that have used this method
have done T Cell injections every other
week for the entire study
so we first checked for safety so we
looked for
erythrocyte concentration within the
blood to determine if cd47 targeting
would have the same off-target issues as
with the cd47 targeted drugs but we do
not see any erythrocyte depletion
supporting that our approach is not
resulting in Optimum targeting of red
blood cells
we did some histology with our tumors
and found that our surf Alpha cv28 TCR T
cells have reduced tumor stroma as shown
in the reduced area of green in the far
right panel and increased levels of
healthy tissue in the yellow and that is
relative to both the TCR T Cell treated
mice in the middle as well as the no T
Cell treated on the left
but what was really exciting was to do
the survival study and see what a
significant shift of the curve that we
achieved with our serpathy 28 tcrt cells
so we were able to increase our median
survival from 31.5 days to 77.5 days and
you can see the significant shift of the
red curve relative to the tcrt
self-control curve in Black so very
excited to to see these results and
continue to develop this publication to
submit later this year
so some conclusions from the switch
receptors are that cd47 is overexpressed
in most tumors and increased expression
of cd47 correlates with reduced survival
and pancreatic ductal adenocarcinoma
twitch receptors can rewire inhibitory
signaling from tumor cells to convert a
negative signal to a positive one
and cd47 targeted switch receptors can
enhance T Cell therapeutic efficacy
without toxicity
so we developed a powerful engineered
protein platform the switch receptors to
provide Coast inventory signals but only
to engineered T cells to significantly
enhance anti-cancer functions
however we know there are multiple types
of immune cells in the body that can be
directed to eradicate cancer
so we asked if we could next generate a
new platform to boost both T cells and
catalyze an anti-cancer response from
other immune cells in the body
so our new platform we've called dual
co-stimulatory receptors or dcrs and
these combine a co-stimulatory ligand
ectodomain with a cost inventory
signaling endodomain so by including his
cost inventory ligand ectodomain we can
provide co-stimulation via customulatory
receptors on the T cell or on other
cells and we still have the coconutorial
signaling endodomain where we can
provide signals that may not be safe to
deliver systemically and should be
restricted to those T cells that we've
targeted to the tumor with an antigen
receptor
so with this approach we asked if our
dcrt cells could stimulate a diverse
anti-tumor response by providing
co-simulatory signals to dendritic cells
endogenous T cells B cells and K cells
and so on
so first we asked if gcrs can enhance T
cell function in a Cell intrinsic manner
so we engineered human T cells with our
dcrs and stimulated them in culture and
what we found is when we looked at cd9
expression which is an activation marker
for T cells our dcrs did indeed promote
increased activation in human T cells
and then that is relative to the full
length Coast inventory ligands where we
just
engineered in the full-length ligands
without any modifications by adding in
that intracellular costingulatory domain
we see enhanced activation of RT cells
we also tested our dcrs with
um human pancreatic cancer cells and so
um whereas the unmodified T cells as are
controlled do not
impact tumor cell uh
lysis we found that our full length
unmodified control also did not promote
these T cells from lysine tumor in this
particular assay but really the
effective dcrs are much more capable of
Lysine tumor and that is shown here with
the ability of these T cells to
lysotumors shown here by the reduction
in tumor signal
so next we asked if gcrs can enhance the
function of other immune cells in a Cell
extrinsic manner
so to do that we generated amateur
dendritic cells from thp1 cells and then
we co-cultured those immature dendritic
cells with our dcrt cells to see if we
could get enhanced interdict cell
maturation so by looking at HOA
upregulation which is class 1 and cd80
which is a co-simulatory ligand for T
cells we indeed found that several dcrs
were able to induce maturation of
dendritic cells in a Cell extrinsic
manner similar to LPS control mature
dendritic cells in the green bars in
both panels
so of course the big question is is that
do these dcrt cells exhibit enhanced
adoptive cell therapy efficacy so the
data that I've shown so far for the dcrs
has been human data so we generated the
murine equivalence and tested them with
um our various assays so here we found
that our dcrt cells our Mouse dcrt cells
were also able to potently lice tumor
and again this is enhanced relative to
the full-length control which is just
the coasting auditory ligand without any
modifications
so we first tested this in our AML
therapy model so for this model we
inject 4 million tumor cells into mice
on day Zero by day five the tumor has
disseminated so we inject T cells after
treating with cyclophosphamide and then
we assess for survival over 100 day
period
and again we're creating an aggressive
tumor situation for our T cells so we're
giving in this model only a single
transfer of T cells and no supportive
bile 2 therapy
so um these data are ongoing but we're
happy to see these initial results that
our dcrs are significantly enhancing T
Cell therapeutic efficacy so here we see
that none of the TCR only T cells were
able uh none of the mice that received
TCR only T cells which is marked as dfp
were able to survive this tumor burden
and in also the full-length postinatory
ligand T cells were unable to rescue the
mice although there was a small shift in
the curve with the blue line but really
the Striking data are with the red green
and orange
um survival curves that show increased
survival from 0 to 29 to 57 percent
we have also initiated testing these
dcrs in our pancreatic tumor model and
so we first did studies where we did
takedowns and looked for our key cells
in the pancreatic tumors
so if we look first in the spleen in the
left panel we see that our dcrt cells
are not overly abundant within the
spleen so they're not just
non-specifically proliferating and
accumulating in non-tumor organs however
in the tumor we see a significant
increase in the number of T cells
relative to both tcrt only
um both the I mean relative to the tcrt
control so these dcrt cells are at 7 to
17 fold higher concentrations in the
tumor
we've also
um been monitoring tumor progressions so
we've been measuring subcutaneous tumors
and so we found that the tumors from our
DCR T Cell recipients are much smaller
than those in the tcrt self-control mice
so some conclusions from our dcrs are
that they provide both cell intrinsic
and extrinsic co-simulatory signals to
improve T cell and endogenous immune
cell anti-tumor activity
the DCR ectodermain co-simulatory
signals are delivered by tumor targeted
T cells which themselves localize to the
tumor so we predict that the cost
inventory signals delivered by the DCR
Ecto domain will be concentrated in the
tumor and less likely to result in
off-target effects such as autoimmunity
and inflammation
and again we have the DCR endodomain
which can provide customulatory signals
that are not safe to deliver
systemically such as cd28
so we've now generated over 75
intentionally engineered Fusion proteins
within my labs and we are generating
data sets to support clinical
translation and what we found is that
these engineered post-stimulatory Fusion
proteins have the potential to overcome
several inhibitory barriers so we've
observed enhanced metabolism of our T
cells reduced or ablated suppression by
decoy mechanism with our switch
receptors reduced exhaustion of our T
cells where they're able to continuously
lice tumor cells or continuously expand
and proliferate in response to multiple
stimulations we've observed a lower
lowered threshold of activation and
increased intra to moral concentration
and with our new platform with our dcrs
we're also observing cell extrinsic
benefits which we are exploring further
so and again we're leaving the
endogenous negative receptor intact and
pairing two native proteins so that we
have a very low immunogenicity of this
approach
so with that I would like to thank the
members of my lab as well as our various
collaborators and our sources of funding
and if you have any follow-up questions
please feel free to reach out to us we
are also looking for
committed scientists to join our group
so if you're interested in that please
let me know
thank you for your time
thank you Dr Oda for your time today and
your important research before we go I'd
like to thank the audience for joining
us today I'd also like to thank our
sponsor stem cell Technologies for
sponsoring today's webinar
questions submitted today and during the
on-demand period will be addressed by
the speaker via the contact information
you provided at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand for
two years until October 5th 2024.
lab routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay and we
encourage you to share that email with
any one of your colleagues who may have
missed today's live event
until next time goodbye